I'm lateYeah.
No no I can't afford to quit
Do you want free do you want free tickets
you want free do you want free chicken you
want free chicken nuggets do you want cream
cheese
I'm sorry
Is not
What's up
WhatMy baby to her.
Something funny
Good morning
Don't you get me something
My not stupid
Xbox
Sleeping
Is inside
Was Ariana Grande
Google
Period
Hey that's bad words
He broke the fourth wall
Behind him
How did you do that
678. 9.
10Cash what is that say under the 11th.
Payment name
Oh let me see
Content creator thing
Tycoon
Yay
All the funny videosThat was a funny sound
video.
Yes like
Okay
I'm in my face
Images
Wow wow wow wow yay
Yes
I don't want this one
Cheeseburger
I got your birthday too
Luke Bryan
CerealCereal game.
B A accept that's how they spell money
Get off and be fatty
You know watching me when I was sleepingYou
were hurting me.
I thought mommy grandma's phone
The way went off my phone
Funny funny
Get you fatty off of me
That's what the law said it said you can't
say it so don't say it I mean yes I can
Tell videos
Ariah
ArayaAriah.
Six Flags Ariel in the blood because she
didn't stick with me with her feet
I don't know
Smashing the buttonS.
About Time Freak Out
A chicken inside no I'm saying thatAnd.
Picture
Ah that mean it's raining
You can't even explain
Too
Hello Lucy
Haha
I like it
Give me that again
It's not me in the butt?
Aaya
Schenectady
By the way
In the pool
Are you doing
All right that's not me in the cheek
Mariah
You in the face
And I didn't do that
I'm sorryMy.
About to dieBy the time.
Boobies
Awesome monster truck
?
Put it down
Costume
Stephanie Lucas Street playing please I
don't miss it OMG tell me something awful
major
Company
Upside down and have some practice
Tonight
AngelTheme song.
Happy Friday
I work all day
Find
Baking soda
Period
It's too hotHow long. Can you put.
YouTubeHot. Ariel.
Here for 5 minutes
True
Shut up
I hate you tooAgain.
I
Beautiful
No
Ariana Grande
LOL
Don't stopStop.
RobloxNow.
There wonder why I want to see somebody
Because
Oh crap I was crying in the carSo sad.
LOL
Mariah
We should do itMake the ram into knocking
down 10 trees.
Give me drivingDirections.
Yeah I can see youOpen.
Phone
SkateboardConsistency that.
I'm going to skate park
Not my birthday pictures
Happy birthday no it's not timeIt's not it's
just the game.
This game on survive
This is like the long walk
Wait a minute
Tammy
I'm jumping see me I'm jumping
Oh sorry
For you to startYeah.
Back in and I'm jumping
Leave it all right
Mario enjoying the party ain't even married
Ocean
I don't mean no
It's still
The people that do this today
2 more minutes
Oh
All right come on it it's about to be in one
more minute
Stepping on your edges
Thug
10:45
You got it to God I'm about the city for
another city God that you got that baby
Don't you stillNo this is actually.
Whenever we went out a cake just use your
camera
Because that'sOoh wildfire. Think Bridget.
Don't take all original
CancelMinutes.
I'm fine Rescue all these kids man
So we have to do the first gift
To burn
Half
Yes scrapping
?
That's all for the first game
Last time this is the last time you're going
to see grass for a while okay
From now onUntil December is over.
Really started
Open the door
And we both have and we both
Sending more rare Luke thank youYes yes.
Please
I got a thorn by tonight but you get
Awesome
I'm transformationHow many carrots do we
need to care too and.
Put two carrots and one cake I'll find
another piece
He maxed it out yeah this Kingdom too I know
I need another
So two carrots and one cake two days
And open right now
Period
I think the flyers or Sam we're going to go
to the second kid
It doesn't work anymore are you ready get
off the booster okay
SoNow.
The regular day
You know I make it I'll make it you love me
Can't get on your Bonita mapOkay.
Elsa wait find the kids time too
And where's my ad with you how are you
supposed to have time
Owner we got glitch in your game
Air take the map offAnd wait for me.
I got Blaze
No come on
Over there
I'll be back
Hey GoogleIncluding a bear.
Well that's a shame
YummyAlright Charlie.
Look at my beard almost there I'm going to
come see youI'm really far.
With you guys
I got Ziggy
Listen
Ing
TameThanks everything man.
Not
Me
Is it my pet
It's sevenI mean next to the fire. It's
time.
To get stuck sometimesStaying with him.
Wait wait don't take all of them
I can wait for three
I really hope that they sit down
I don't think I can take that much
textConcern.
I'm sorry mocha
No no come back AriahI actually pooped.
Where.
Bro come here you guys
We don't have that thing
Know please you guys you need to sit down
Can I release some of themNo we're going to
need them.
Come on y'allLet's fight.
Okay yeah
Yeah you runWhat do you you all need an
admin flashlight.
YesAnd admin. Leave.
Okay you guys get up lateI'm leaving.
We need to get the second kids come on we
don't have to fight
Want to come oh I forgot to think
Come on let's go
Go eat first
Never mind
StopNice I needed that.
All right I'm laggingI'm glad it. Okay.
Bring Batman 5 minutes
I think we had too many so they have
No answerMine I think they're still at the
no they would respond when you die.
So likeThe other day. Don't worry.
I'm going through my kids backOkay.
Let's go y'allOh I got my man is that
Snickers.
Oh my God all of them are backI knew
something. No don't.
Tell me
Come on y'all we got to Revenge my bestie
Come on
Help y'all
Money
Come on Snickers
I want to release my man
Out
Where we'llWe're releasing all of my.
I can see more
Time
Nothing special
But I know
Oh myI'll miss you guys.
Can't wait
But it just started
Homophobic
Actual update is in 3 minutes
Thank you
Spider-Man game to see the music
Did you know if you make ribs for the deerHe
will help you again.
Feel like it's something
Weird
Yeah I know you took pity on me
Song
Download
Button
Damn it
Thomas Jefferson family
Just
Wondering ifIt's like that.
I love you I love you baby
Stop acting like speed live stream and be
quiet
New
Cappuccino
I don't know how to say it but
Yeah that's a picture please
Just tell it to me
And nothing
Will kiss you
Oh yeah
So
New games
Where's the strawberry
What do you like the most special
CoffeePlace.
Fishing room
Do you want
I'm just waiting until it's time for the
First time for your ownSeriously.
Hello
I know you said you were a property and
stuff buying my first car
People's flashlightOkay.
You you always
Just caught the guy literally a few moments
ago
Regre
Know you by name
I'm so hungry just come to my castle with me
This is my mother yo what's
Good
Afternoon
Period
Don't go around the location
Go ahead on you have to show me your
bathroom before I'm going to have to give
you a ticket
I don't have to show you nothing well I
sorry
He didn't have to chase
Friends
MiaAnd. Kardashian Molina.
The museum
Google
You know
I kind of luxury cars
Best friend
Will you be mad at me if I follow my ex on
her socials I can't control you you don't
want to work done
See you again
Looking for a fish preferably with no teeth
I don't remember
Those are red stems are green I freaking
can't waitTill you turn 18.
No problem I don't want to let you know man
I got it before
Start a timer for 18 years you could have
three of any superpowers
???????
Don't
Is this birthday to me
RachelBut yeah.
You really want to know what it is
becauseBefore you tell me.
Oh yeah
Did you
By the way I'm out of deodorant
White boy
AbilityComing from school.
District
It's
Call Paul
Please
Washington
So I thought about taking someone else's
food however
About for future
Well maybe telephone
Number from the upper level so I thought
about taking someone else's food however as
soon as I picked up a piece of chicken with
Tony from the upper level stopped me he told
me I could only eat my own food this was the
rule of the Loyalists because if someone
steals food it means the people below will
go hungry I explained by someone else to
break the rules I didn't want to hear their
explanation I just wanted to compensation
told me that if they couldn't beat that
person Jenny and I would need to prepare for
a fight
To prepare for the enemy when the platform
came down I was stunned I saw a course
quietly
Platform started moving down to the next
floor Tony told us to quickly clear the food
and the room returned to its normal
temperature because of the thieves disregard
for the rules today's food could not be
eaten in the fight so the people below had
no food to eat from the third day on I began
to follow the rules I only ate my own pizza
everyday straight and suddenly had an idea
however they didn't expose me
Time to change floors good news came from
downstairs that food could be delivered
intact to the 175th floor Jenny and I
happily started dancing but when we woke up
the next day we found we had been assigned
to the 180th floor of floor where food had
never reached I looked at the pizza in my
hand I noticed that the toppings
Baby but normal human being
Hey baby
Baby
Better baby
Nobody
Mobile
Walk to Market
Turkey recipe
For 15
Did you tell me one of my friend
Oh that's Ranch
And why do we need a
Baby
And why do we need it
Tell me what youDon't know.
Hey baby
Now baby boy do you have
YouTube 20 + 5
What can we just be normal Deadpool
Football practice
What
WomanHe told me.
If you wantSomething.
Good Fortune
Baby
Mama told me both
Facebook
If it was funny well I'm going to sleepWhy.
Peanut butter
Hey what I'm leaving
StupidI hate you Sammy.
Do you like it
Perfect
Good night thank youRight. Here.
Period
I started playing funk you to call me
Jingle bell song
The smallest planet I woke up in the
hospital
I think I might think that I woke up in the
The smallest dining room
Tomorrow
It's not starting that I think I might be
that I woke up in the hospital with pictures
of nice talking
About
S
Bitches in my head oh Jingle Bells fuck
yourself probably tonight Batman monster
Batman movie
Pictures in my head
Phones
Cannot Escape
I don't think you're not be fine if not
really funny
Where are you
YouTube YouTube
Now I'm going to be in love
OMG
I I love you
You can touch it
7 daysThat's seven days.
No cash
Said no
No return
Amy because the only kid 99 days
To your boyfriend
Hey
MickeyMouse.
But don't don't make real friends like very
far it's very far
Does the deer might see you
Doing that
It's not the fire
YesNowadays.
Wait don't say somethingWait.
It's Christmas timeFor the 25th is. Yeah.
Right now
Because he said this I have a sack for kids
To his friend
Miranda vegan shop I still haven't completed
it
Actually
Understand
Any music
And mommy don't want to see you in love with
myself
Your University okay wait
Why
Are you doingPassionate let me drive her
because.
30 seconds
When you kill
Shut upHe's trying to. Eat.
Sing TwinkleFar away at like. 50.
Days
For one is Winston
You have a laser gun
You know the ugly
Weird theme songIn the forest.
Gems
Yellow
You see the first kid already
Got a good appBring me a picture.
Rihanna
When interviewing 99 in the firstStandings.
Somebody to save the father said and they
won already
Smiley faceTupac reindeer.
Awesome reindeerLego store.
You wanted to join me nobody told you to
Drums now you got to stayBut.
Don't be around I want to do itGo don't
don't talk to me you can leave.
But don't ask to play with me if y'all leave
Batman videos
Minecraft rap game and
Hey Brother laser
EBay
Have you been dancing
Watching
Lucky blockLucky block.
S
Let me knowLet me.
Hey what's popping you
Go open the lucky
Number oh no not that big guyNot too much.
Nobody talking to you.
Either
You can take that for 1 minute
And you said that red
That's what I got yesThat's what I thought.
Why is it
And I will sell it in front of your face
I like a birthday
Cake
Please be one of themI hate this game.
It'll do it like it's loveI miss you.
Baby
I love you
This is my basement box
Es
So3K.
I'm so sorry
For Christmas
No because if you're not if you're naughty
until Christmas time you're not going to get
any pregnant stop being bad at school
Cashland he's not mine
I'll be naughtyAriel and for you.
Barbie own
Pick presentPicture.
Do you want to watch me whip watchEs.
Hampton
Football
Welcome how much money how much candy canes
you got in a bottle 151 yes he's doing it
now yeah
Now
Hello why you dancing againI can't even like
with that.
And this is so likeAccepted Google.
Is real life is on the roofDown the road.
What are boysBecause he wants to steal my.
That you found firstYeah. But he.
Delete I don't want a job pleaseI don't want
a job I'm scared of them.
Who is slaps youThat just.
Ice
Job doctor scared of a jobWhat do y'all
think of the North Pole event I love it
Sammy.
Thank youI love it.
On TuesdayOn Taco Tuesday.
Business world of cheese bag
Close your base tomorrow I can stillThank
you for telling me Cashland.
I just found out thank you so much
I want to say why isn't the breaking border
Know
Love you I got it and you didn'tLove you
all.
Don't like this one
Somebody slap you 43 Kayla
I'm just waiting until
You want to see it yeah
Santa
Maria
I'll call me a question happy cuz it's
really bad
Yeah I know the baby
Hey baby
Oh yes semi slap you on the road
That might not be on the moon
Not a cat oh kitty catsThere's a little
Kathy's.
Yeah I told you happy dollsBro your name is
luck but you don't have any luck.
My name is not look no look at this face it
says look
But he doesn't have any base it doesn't even
have anything
Yeah
Go away
Santa tell me one minute
Do you really think I'm stupid
Thank you
I wasn't doing anything
NothingBro that means.
That boy's name is lucky book I almost
bought this strawberry
Rainbow day
Or laugh people Japanese High rainbowsGames.
?
Spider-Man Spider-ManGot it.
Back
Why is everythingWhy you watching Netflix.
Thank you
GoogleNickel option.
Anybody
Candy game
Two kids designer
One okay
I hate this gameCash that's not.
A songPlease.
That's that's Ariel
No don't talk to me
Baby how many hot dogs do you need
Me
Nothing nothing
DefinitionYou.
Know
Nothing
No baby
Hey Google
ButterCheese.
Minecraft house
Nobody can take you
I don't hold it so nobody can take it
What is this boy doing
It again
Greenhouse Stone sophomore
A surprise
He just found out Virginia Beach Virginia
Bird he's right back homeStatement.
S
What is the most likely
Been like this one
Word
Oh my
Peter there's nobody there what are you
talking about
Nobody there what he's talking about
You
Strawberry rock paper
Event New York running down to August 17th
What is this point doing
It's an illusion something happens
In
What is he doing
Anything
Hey we don't have problems
Okay and
I don't know
The rainbow restaurant
In your Purina what happened in the
rainIest.
We got
100 45 50 50
What are we going to happenYet.
I willBaby up.
Skip
My boy
Ariana Grande
Question mark
Batman amazing cop cop cop
Then leave
You don't see it
You know tomorrow
That is it's Drama lyrics
Have to start with a t
He doesn't mean
Gangster blue Tara
Please get back baby I made it
Easy
Spray
Facebook.com
When I needed that when I go home
Yeah
Hey why do you laughing
NoNo.
You didn't never leave me
Alone
Don't get under everything
That's mean
Lullabies
I don't know
Do that cake the black cake I see your hair
Ariel
I saw a grandma
Macho
Coachella little jalala doesn'tHappen.
What's 3 * 9 * 3 + 9 9 10 11 12
16 * 7 6 7.
Wait6. 7. 6 7.
8 7 7
103 yes
So I can get all the the thingsI said 7 and
67.
No need
Gymnastics to 70 you got 2721 I know where
the blue point is
Not easy
Crazy moneyRed yellow.
Red yellow
That's not interested okay I'll try again
I hate this game let me know
Why do you
No
Emoji that was in the wall
Meeting find the rainbow Chucky
Baby doesn't mean no
That's awesome
I'm still looking in the sky first
You don't look
After
I saidI said.
You
You have to stop talking
So you can hear me
Know
I'm right here
Before you sit down and then I'm okay
I don't even get up there
Now
You enjoy man
You did leaving
All done trash
I got here
I said but that doesn't mean 30
Then20 this was made in China.
Made in ChinaFunny 1980.
14 13 12 11 10 9 8 7 6 3 2 1
Can you make me laugh
No I didn'tNo more time.
To go to that game I meant that one and then
that
Very top floor he now I'm going to go back
up there go to try moving time I said no I
will help you
No
Minecraft place it's unlocked
Wait until
Until 4 minutes30 minutes.
That was you
But ArielBody.
I feel yourself
Nothing like myself
If I did under my head it's out there
Excuse me I don't even mean
?
Pink and blue on my face
Pink and blue
On my favorite cupSo pink and name on my
break.
If there's a bag it's going to be pink
Ie Pie
Right
Use items
Free
Something
No you feel like no
People like
Ariana stupid
No you're literally asking me a question
ManAll right come here mommy said.
Get back to the area
I I definitely do it I was definitely wrong
You definitely have likeYour house. Like.
Stupid
Are you coming iPad or like
Xbox
Stop
Character lay it in the beginningShe said
come here.
I need to restart cuz I disconnected my spot
where you did not disconnect yes I did
The game cuz I disconnected damn phone I
moved I'm not playing that
Join me
Stop donating treeOff.
And waitRight what are you doing stop.
Ping Ariel
YeahAnd and I wasn't in the park.
Shut up
It's that problem why are you
Abandonment
Why why are you worried about what I'm going
to cuz you are Mama
Happy birthday
Alabama shoes
WhatOh yeah really y'all really rather have
MacDonald Had.
I want juice too
In my life mama
Whenever
He blamed you but I know whoThey told you.
Can you find me a blanketI will get in.
New spirit oh nice if I'm gingerbread
Italian
Air traffic and it's going to kill you
Run out ofHad a bullish don't say nothing.
Tell
Caillou
No bring it backDoor. Forever.
I really hope everything I need you
You never got me my buddy but
I don't know anything
Cuz I'm already going to die today I'm about
to be sorry
I'm okay I'm on my way to go visit us
Today yeah since you don't know how to get
through I can get to
Strawberry and he's going to die
So go on tonight
Make sure you get all that food
Well you don't have to miss out
No I got a good answer
Find me some food
You said you didn't have that now I just got
it for now
Hey how are you leaving
We're stuck with mother freakingFreaking.
Thinks it Little Caesars Pizza cuz of y'all
why because we can't afford to go to shit
I want to see Pizza
Too you got your nuggets
I want to know it
Because you don't have enough money for both
Ariel
Wow he just met his phone so hard he broke
itSo far.
They said we're no longer going to be grass
anymore
Now 19 19 12 11 10 9 8
7 85 4 3 2 1 4 3 2 1.
China time
Now stay cool
Dance
No
No you didn't got a rainbow
Have you done yet
No?.
Ice skates this morning
Oh yes
I just need to know where to upgrade
But some helpful
Anyway
How much points do you have
Aria grandma
This
25 by The Escape
Go party
Okay
I have bandagesSpirit of sound back.
Ariah Ariel
Ariel
Go around
Can I have a can I have it please
I need it cuz I need to explore
Yeah
No
Talking
Tom
Baby
You can leave at home
Mommy
Call Mommy
First
I was born first
I'm at work
You was born in in your mom
TomorrowThe bed. For bed.
Dixie number
We had like four Bottoms in there
Frozen movie
That's what's not
Good
You
JumpSuperman.
Dash can you give me my
Daddy
Nobody take it please
OK GoogleWhat I will take it I won't let you
take it.
Easy
Stop okay period
Say sorryNo say sorry to Ariel.
Say sorry to hear you say sorry to hear you
say sorry
Cuz you don't know how to apologize
That picture
Hello who said
Ates
Flashlight on
Your lips
Question
All right
My kids now my makeup
Okay
Let's just walk
ByeYou. Great spot.
S
I get out
Alive
I don't know videos
Salt Shaw is your last name
Yeah but YahooI.
I'm not calling attached anymore I'm calling
you attachments
Ariel yellow kill people
Follow me you die
I told youEverybody.
For everybody else
Away
Slowly people
Games that you look that y'all like even
like to play X's
They like to like continue walking and
playing Roblox I don't want to move like
I don't want toDo the other one to plus X on
your screen.
But I had to
But yeah but you don't want you to actually
Ariel
That means if you don't want to end up like
You
Without even thinking about itPeriod.
Supposed to be there because they're her
kids too and how she's their mom and did me
isn't the same without them the whole thing
was so ridiculous I just started laughing I
mean what did she expected last year
Without even thinking about it
Sarah let me choose the gameGood morning.
Mister prices
Day 13
For the calendarNo don't leave me.
Come back for the first time
6 7 8 9 10 11 and 12Camel.
From the Royal TheaterThe six isn't open.
But there's a streetOr what.
16 your next gift
I want super kisses
Don't show me what it is and downtown
What is it what kind of thing it is
Useless
Change your foodChain.
6Or I'm 67.
Now
Not sure
Up
Alive with her babies
I haven'tI didn't even find that place
Ariel.
Cash for not talking about pets
We're talking Allison
Report
I'm thirsty mother
To uniformWait we need to only come.
Okay
To go to the park and thanks
I'm going to have some water
And after this you have ice skating lessons
It's coffee
Nobody can be my writerMy personal best is
one minute.
Okay wellSee you later.
I will we have to meet you at home
On teleport to me
Where's your house your ownWait.
There
I'm going to see if you like another one out
Especially the money waitGet dressed for
bed.
No man cancel
Somebody go to sleep in Period
Restaurant
Get you ready forTomorrow.
That's why you just said oh no it's fine
Not yetI want you to be Brown.
Yeah
Can I get dressedSchool clothes.
Yes
Are you ready to go yeah you want to go get
onCar or motorcycle.
Accident
Hey baby
Daddy baby
I'll come pick you up after I'm done with
work
Ariel what84. 45.
1 2 2
24 + 32 = 67
Everyone's pictures
Google Rihanna new baby up I need water
Can you give me a bunch of water
All right why is there a whole door to
someone's house
Please
NFLNo.
?
Come outside
Come outside honey
Oh excuse me I'm outside I'm outside you're
not supposed to sleep here get up
It's night time night time shut up
Where's your pets
Mariah
Okay
Closer on bedYou forgot to get ready for
bed.
Google
Go take a shower
I tried to be early this time okay make sure
you come to my room when you're ready when
you're ready yes I do
Know
When you get your addressNashville.
Definition.
It's notTomorrow's Friday. Huh.
No no okay I'm fine please
Yes perfect
I like my jacket
Okay
You didn't see all those carsNo. Air so I
forgot to go up on my foot.
Good morning
I love you
That's a stroller
I need a lot of water
Ariah
ImagesI bought it challenge.
You can buy that guy that's running
Thanks
In my luxurious home now
Need to change my hand
Girl
Look up Nike Bros
No do that during some
Years ago
I don't
That was Jerry's car was a toy car alarm
For me wait how much is thatFree 1,000 and.
Oh never mind it's 11,000
Beautiful campingYeah.
But Friday
Wait but they they close the banks
nowThey're supposed to showers.
They close me back yeah when it's not time
to goLook.
Why would you leave
80What is that. A pet.
A mini carsMannequin keep your eye on it.
Hey Ariel so let's go homeAnd he said.
Go take a showerI was trying to say I'm
going to go take a shower.
I get to cheer your clothes on yes I know
I got something important
Bad
Oh hell no
Mariah I want you to know that it was
nothing you did
Personally I said a really long day at work
And I don't feel like talking
But I also don't feel like being an ass to
one of my favorite nieces so I'm sorry
But I had my moment of silence y'all can cut
up the music and stuff again I just needed
my timeTimes over you can cut your shit up.
Thank you appreciate you for understanding
And I'm sorry I'm like that but I'm like
thatThat was yesterday.
Aria and Carmen not here but they should be
here tomorrow
If it was me I have 3 million right now
That's how you got all your views by killing
your viewersAll right I see it now.
Yeah I just got this new spot
Oh shit show me the last office
I understand
All right
InboxEs. Please.
In the day in the life bro still breathing
so we're still here
About to head back out whenYeah.
I already know bro I already know the vibes
You're at that point where you sleeping in
your uniform Julius yeah that's that's that
shit that's that shit don't think I ain't
been there bro
You think I ain't been here again wake me up
at 4:35
Will will will evict every fucking thing in
this house if you wake me up at 4:31
And that's the crazy part if you wake me up
at 4:31We will have.
To eat don't waste my love
Be on target with this shit I'm telling you
I have very little room for air and I don't
got time for patients
You wake me up 2 minutes early cuz you
thought you was being slick and you have
ruined my entire week
Set It Off you might as well give me the new
clothes you might as well you might as well
you might as well
Go ahead and burn that bitch down bro the
whole shit about to come to a crash
And so sorry for Ari bro I put way too much
pressure on that girl
That's how that hole in that bathroomDidn't
get woke up on his birthday and I woke up to
being fired.
You know in my mind right if I'm working two
jobs and I don't wake up on time and ain't
nobody else in this bitch working
That ain't my faultI said it I don't care if
I sound wrong.
And y'all know how I feel I take it I take
the blame for everything no not this one no
not that and I'm working two jobs I can't do
nothing else
I got time for job one job to sleep and job
one and job too
And it don't stop people from coming to
collect when the paycheck said and I know
how that should feel too I blow through my
first chicken still had a second one not
even trip
Not even trip every little tip I was getting
going straight to baby girl just for waking
me up that's it
She made so much bread while I was at that
strip club but I know she was a baller
Trying to hit this wake up
Appreciate
And on some shit
This one for the rapSomeone don't taste is
good but it's something and it ain't
nothing.
Bro what have a great day at work
I'm sorry I just looked up and you only have
4,000
Broken
I'm sorry when I looked up you had 5,000 I
broke it I'm sorry I'm sorry my bad my bad
my bad
Maybe if you had real videos instead of
watching people do backstreet boy dances
then you have a little bit more cash and no
These little short ass video 42 minute
videos think you did something
What happens at 101
Oh then that's Max money
And you can only carry one video at a time
No that's why you are broke
I make them one movie on that ass
You thought it was one movieYou got five.
How much money we talking aboutAre you
finally not a broken.
Got 75,000
How you thought of something everybody
wasn't
So that is nice
Oh never mind you ain't even unlock that
studio over there
Hell noWhat are you doing.
Buying decorations and shitThen you wonder
why you were broken.
And West all your money on decorations if
it's not putting more money in our pocket
windows we don't want it
AndAnd what's upstairs. You ain't been
upstairs this whole time I don't even know
what's up t